Gretchen Kraft Reuben is Kansas City's
missionary to New York City and to
Washington DC we are we are doing our
best to civilize the further reaches of
of American land and we've sent Gretchen
off to do that and she's done a great
job of it she's she's been an
undergraduate and a law student at Yale
successfully completed there became a
law clerk to Sandra Day O'Connor and as
you know justice O'Connor is waiting for
for Gretchen to finish her book tours so
that she can replace her on the Supreme
Court she was a chief adviser to
chairman Reed Hundt at the the FCC and
and she has established a great career
as an author at bringing a little
civilization to all of us she wrote a
great book that was published a little
over a year ago on Winston Churchill for
it at 40 ways to to look at Winston
Churchill in the book that she'll be
talking about tonight the 40 ways to
look at JFK is in some ways a sequel to
that best-selling and wonderful book and
she's also published a book that about
her bringing of civilization to to the
East Coast power money fame sex the
users guide and and all of these books
are are very well written there are
thoughtful books and they're thoughtful
books on on interesting subjects and and
we welcome Gretchen Kraft Rubin after
her missionary activities to the East
Coast back to back to Kansas City
Gretchen
well certainly it's a tremendous delight
to be here and at this gorgeous library
and to see so many people so I'm so
thrilled to be here and I was asked to
start by talking a little bit about how
I made the transition from being a
lawyer to writing and I had a great
experience as a lawyer I went to Yale
Law School was editor-in-chief of Yale
Law Journal and as Chris is saying I
went to clerk for a Sandra Day O'Connor
but while I was clerking on the weekends
for fun I was working on a book project
on the subject of power money fame and
sex and you might think that clerking
isn't a particularly helpful place to be
doing that research except that one of
the little-known perks of being a
Supreme Court justice
is that you can actually check out books
from the Library of Congress and what
the librarians the Library of Congress
thought about the fact that somebody in
justice o'connor's chambers was checking
out books like deep in the heart of
Texas the true story of three sisters
who were all Dallas Cowboy Cheerleaders
I do not know but I made the most of
that opportunity but when I was trying
to figure out what I was going to do
next with my career I had an epiphany I
went over to the house of a friend who
was in education graduate school and she
had a bunch of very thick dry looking
books in her living room and I said oh
is this the kind of thing you have to
read for your program and she said well
it's the kind of thing I read on my own
anyway and I reflected on the fact that
as much as I enjoyed my job I never
spent one more minute on it than I had
to and for fun I was working on a book
and it occurred to me that some people
do that for a living
so I got a book about how to write a
book proposal and I wrote a book
proposal and then I got an agent and a
book contract and made the full time
switch to writing my time at the Supreme
Court though really helped me when I
decided that I wanted to work on
biography at the Supreme Court I'd often
had the jarring experience of reading an
absolutely compelling legal brief and
then reading an equally compelling
opposing brief and seeing both sides
marshal
facts precedent and case law to support
quite opposite conclusions and I saw the
same thing in biography if you read a
good biography you think that you have a
decent sense of the subject but if you
read six or seven biographies of the
same person you begin to detect the
machinations of biographers and how
they're shaping your conclusions by the
way they're presenting the facts to you
so when I set out to write a biography
of Winston Churchill I decided to write
a biography that would present both the
admiring view and the critical view I
portrayed Churchill by looking at him
from multiple angles and that's the 40
ways the 40 ways ask the reader to look
at Churchill in many ways some positive
some negative when was a timeline one
was nothing but a map of the British
Empire at its height and by doing so to
consider the problems inherent in
biography and that's of course the same
approach that I use with Kennedy and
this structure allows me to deal clearly
with many themes without having to weave
them through hundreds of pages of
chronology it allows me to focus on the
most important aspects of my subjects
life and leave out all the boring parts
and it allows me to say a lot about a
large subject in a very short book I
show that the facts support a biography
of Kennedy the idealistic and courageous
statesman and Kennedy the shallow
opportunist he was a great leader who
inspired Americans with his vision of a
greater country and he was a gifted
entertainer who distracted Americans
with glamorous photographs and witty
one-liners I convey the debate over
Kennedy's character and accomplishments
and allow the reader to judge so you
read this biography and you feel like
you've read not just one biography but
it doesn't a question people often asked
me though they phrased it very
diplomatically is does the world really
need another biography of JFK hasn't his
story already been told a hundred times
and for that matter is he really worthy
of
this attention was he truly great
obviously I did think there was a need
for another biography of JFK and as for
the question of whether Kennedy was
truly great I was not sure about that
when I undertook this book when I
started writing about Churchill I knew
that I believed that he was a hero
I detail his flaws and his limitations
in my book and I never forgot them but I
knew that I believed in his greatness
but I wasn't sure about Kennedy I
honestly didn't know if I was going to
conclude that Kennedy was like Martin
Luther King jr. a great leader though
flawed or more like Princess Diana
someone whose public stature really
seems based on buzz and glamour and not
on real accomplishment and in fact one
of my chief reasons for wanting to write
about Kennedy was to make up my mind on
it exactly that topic was Kennedy truly
great and in the end I did decide the
Kennedy was truly great and coming to
that realization and explaining it was
one of my favorite parts of writing this
book a related question and one of the
most fascinating questions about Kennedy
it was what made Kennedy Kennedy why was
it that despite a presidency that lasted
just two years ten months and two days
George Bush has more time remaining in
office than Kennedy had in office and a
presidency that took place more than 40
years ago people still find him in
exhaustively fascinating and although
most scholars maintain that Kennedy's
abbreviated presidency was unremarkable
the public disagrees a 2004 Gallup poll
ranked Kennedy as the second most
outstanding president and a 2003 Gallup
poll showed Kennedy and Lincoln tied for
first place
Kennedy stature isn't a recent trend in
1970 Harris poll showed that Kennedy was
by far the most popular president as did
in 1983 Gallup poll Kennedy was also
enormous ly popular while in office
early in his term he had a higher
approval rating than either Roosevelt or
Eisenhower which is astonishing when you
think that he had barely defeated
Richard Nixon in the polls not long
before and all the presidents whose
ratings have been measured Kennedy still
holds the record for the highest average
approval rating at 70 percent and JFK
continues to hold any unique stature
this is a copy of Newsweek magazine from
earlier this year it was a special
edition that was prepared for the World
Economic Forum at Davos and the theme of
the special issue is leadership and to
illustrate that theme we have three
pictures Kennedy in the sector supreme
position flanked by Churchill and
Roosevelt in this issue there are
articles by Sir Martin Gilbert and Jon
Meacham both whom of whom have written
extensively about Churchill and
Roosevelt and the war and who write here
about the lessons for George Bush from
Churchill and Roosevelt and World War
two but there is nothing in the magazine
about Kennedy and yet he's the one who's
in the center on the front of the
magazine and we take this Kennedy
phenomenon for granted because we're so
accustomed to it but why does this
public seized on Kennedy with such
fervor this question what made Kennedy
Kennedy wasn't a question that could be
answered by gaining access to newly and
classified files or doing another round
in interviews it would require me to
make sense of what was already known
many argue that Kennedy's ideals his
eloquence his goals account for the
public's admiration others point instead
to his glamour his fortune his wit his
public relations his wife and family his
terrible death and I decided to examine
each of these factors in turn I wanted
to look at his father Joe's influence
and it's clear that at every step Joe
had an enormous impact on his cousin's
career to give you a sense of the
intensity of Joe's involvement here just
a few highlights when Jack was writing
his Harvard
your thesis gel was in London as
ambassador to the court of st. James Joe
wrote letters to Jack that Jack used as
a source of ideas and often quoted
verbatim in the thesis and when it was
finished
Joe enlisted influential New York Times
journalist author croc to help get it
published as a book Joe played a big
role in prodding Jack to get involved in
politics his first step was to identify
a seat after discovering that
congressman James Michael Curley had
serious financial problems just sent him
twelve thousand dollars and promised him
more financial support if he would leave
the seat and run for mayor of Boston and
Curley did that left open the 11th
district seat in Massachusetts ten men
ran for the open seat
the Kennedys offered the front-runner
Mike Neville a job from life if he would
drop out another candidate was a man
named Joseph Russo Joe paid a janitor
named Joe Russo to put his name on the
ballot to dilute the Joseph Russo vote
when Jack decided to run for Senate
against popular incumbent Henry Cabot
Lodge in 1952 Joe bought the Boston Post
endorsement then worth an estimated
40,000 votes by promising the publisher
a $500,000 loan now Jack Kennedy was a
master at using self-deprecating humor
to take the sting out of criticism and
he often joked about his father's role
at the 1958 gridiron dinner he pretended
to read a telegram from his father dear
jack don't buy a single vote more than
is necessary I'll be damned if I'm going
to pay for a landslide
at a dinner in 1960 JFK said I announced
earlier this year that if successful I
would not consider campaign
contributions as a substitute for
experience in employing ambassadors ever
since I made that statement I have not
received one single cent from my father
Jack Kennedy never denied his father's
influence and he was always grateful to
his father he's the one who made all
this possible Jack Kennedy said not long
before he was assassinated and just as
Joe Kennedy was a huge factor in Jack
Kennedy's triumphs it's impossible to
talk about his successes without
detailing the contribution of his wife
Jackie and it's astonishing to think
that she became first lady at the age of
31 and now she's considered an
outstanding example of a first lady but
at the time
Kennedy's advisors fretted over her they
thought she should be more political or
more homey or less sophisticated but
Jackie paid no attention and Kennedy
didn't press her too hard to change a
man marries a woman not a first lady he
said if he becomes president
she must fit her own personality into
her own concept of a first lady's role
people do best what comes naturally and
Jackie did become essential to her
husband's success young attractive with
adorable children and a distinctive
personality her ability to attract
crowds and cameras made her a
significant asset and like JFK she
seemed to be able to do everything well
if she wasn't speaking French to General
de Gaulle she was dancing the twist with
Defense Secretary Robert McNamara or
waterskiing with astronaut John Glenn on
their famous trip to France Kennedy said
I do not think it altogether
inappropriate to introduce myself to
this audience I am the man who
accompanied Jacqueline Kennedy to Paris
and I enjoyed it
the chapters that discuss Joe and Jackie
Kennedy are written in straight
narrative form I've always been
intrigued however by how the framework
in which facts are
scented influences our understanding so
some of the 40 ways exploit
unconventional forms one thing you have
to consider when evaluating JFK is his
physical condition it's very hard to
comprehend just how bad his medical
condition was and I have a chapter that
is nothing but a timeline that
chronicles his medical history and I
think seeing the information that way
but it makes a much greater impression
on the reader
I couldn't resist using the 40 way
structure to include a long list of my
favorite Kennedy one-liners he had a
very distinctive style throughout his
life and a good example is a letter that
he wrote from the South Seas in 1944
when he wrote to his brother Bobby then
17 who had just joined the Navy the
folks sent me a clipping of you taking
the oath the sight of you there just as
a boy was really moving particularly as
a close examination showed that you had
my checked London coat on
a lot of his great lines show his
interest in history and biography he
once reminded listeners that for one
brief moment of glory he'd been a
candidate for vice president Socrates
once said that it was the duty of a man
of real principle to avoid fine a tional
office and evidently the delegates at
Chicago recognized my principles even
before I did when the microphone at the
st. Paul Airport didn't work he joked I
understand a Daniel Webster used to
address a hundred thousand people
without a mic we're a little softer than
they used to be however of Ted Kennedy's
race against Eddie McCormack for the US
Senate Kennedy said we'd rather be dead
than dead he once remarked of the
peaceful civil rights sit-ins that it is
the American tradition to stand up for
one's rights even if the new way to
stand up for one's rights is to sit down
and I used an unusual structure in a
chapter that I called Kennedy revised
which seeked sought to show how some of
the myths that surrounded Kennedy were
perpetuated and in this chapter I adjust
opposed different versions of events the
version that was presented at the time
and the version that emerged later when
more facts came to life so here's an
account that was published in 1961 it's
Teddy White's very famous making of the
president in 1964 the crowds that
erupted some greet Kennedy in the
streets in the last few weeks of the
campaign were and remain unbelievable it
was not their numbers that made them
spectacular but their frenzied quality
one remembers being in a Kennedy crowd
and suddenly sensing far off on the edge
of it a ripple of pressure beginning and
the ripple would grow like a wave until
it would squeeze the front rake of the
crank of the crowd against the wooden
barricade and the barricade would
splinter then in 1971 Gerry Bruno and
Jeff Greenfield published a book called
the advance man which was an account to
the advance work that they did for the
Kennedy presidential campaigns the crowd
began to push forward they knocked down
the snow fence and swarmed all over
Kennedy sharing and reaching out to
shake his hand my god Kennedy said after
I can't believe that crowd how did you
do it it looks so good on filming in the
press that from then on we made sure the
crowd surged over Kennedy I'd have two
men holding a rope by an airport or
along a motorcade then at the right time
they just dropped the rope and the
crowds would rush close to Kennedy and
here's an account of Kennedy's his speed
reading a 1961 article called the
president's voracious reading habits was
written by Hugh citee in Life Magazine
just how fast Kennedy reads has not been
precisely determined but his speed is at
least 1,200 words per minute and
sometimes more than that the average
person reads 250 words per minute then
in 1963 Hugh's side he published a
biography of John called John F Kennedy
President Kennedy read from 1,200 to
2,000 words a minute maybe faster when
the going was light then in 1966
Kennedy's army buddy read Fay published
a memoir called the pleasure of his
company when I first came to Washington
my reading speed was about 400 words a
minute
I took a speed reading course and got it
up to about 800 words a minute with
about 90% comprehension but I knew that
the president read about 2200 were 2400
words a minute with almost total
comprehension in his oral history at the
Kennedy Library Hugh's side he admitted
that he'd allowed Kennedy to negotiate
for the 1200 words per minute number the
speed reading Institute where Kennedy
had taken his course couldn't confirm
such a high rate of speed and suggested
that given that the average person reads
250 words a minute 700 or 800 words was
the likely estimate the president didn't
like that one bit society after
discussion side II and Kennedy agreed
that side he would report a reading
speed of 1200 words per minute I noted
for months and years after sight he said
with an apparent lack of any feeling of
responsibility that this became their
real gospel on this reading speed
as I said earlier when I started working
on the book one of the main questions I
wanted to answer for myself was whether
Kennedy's stature is based on substance
or an image and many people argue that
Kennedy's perceived greatness is just a
matter of money image making and
manipulation and in fact there are many
instances where the facts were distorted
in order to boost Kennedy's reputation
one example is the famous incident in
the South Pacific in August 1943 when a
Japanese destroyer rammed and split the
small patrol torpedo boat Kennedy was
skippering Kennedy became a hero when he
led his men to safety and kept them
together until help arrived what was
largely overlooked however was the
question of why a small highly
maneuverable PT boat was rammed by a
Japanese destroyer in all of World War
two that's the only time that that
happened and why the crew failed to
notice a destroyer bearing down on them
when other pts had picked it up a mile
or so distant was never fully explained
Kennedy himself later admitted that he
hadn't known whether the Navy would give
him a medal or throw him out Kennedy
admirers often point to the fact that he
won the Pulitzer Prize in biography in
1957 for his book Profiles in Courage
in fact his winning of the prize was
questionable profiles and courage hadn't
ranked among the judges five
recommendations for biography to the
Pulitzer advisory board but in an
unusual move the board awarded it to
Kennedy Rose Kennedy acknowledged that
it was the careful spade work on their
father's part as to who was on the
committee and how to read such and such
a person through steps in such a friend
that secured the Pulitzer for the
profiles and courage Rose recalled that
Jill often said things don't happen they
are made to happen but the chief
controversy isn't even about the awards
process but whether Kennedy actually
wrote the book it's clear he had the
idea for the book and edited it and took
responsibility for its contents but
other people
actually did the work of gathering the
information and writing it down on paper
of course politicians often write books
and speeches in this way but the
Pulitzer is a writing prize and it was
Kennedy who won the Pulitzer Kennedy
always insisted that he had written the
book but he made no drafts related to
most of the books material and little of
what he did draft made it into the final
version while the book was being written
he was very ill he was recovering from
two major operations and was
hospitalized additional times traveling
in Europe or making national appearances
to raise his visibility in preparation
for a presidential run Ted Sorensen by
contrast worked on the book full-time
for six months often for 12-hour days
but while it's easy to point out
episodes where Kennedy took steps to
manipulate his image it's much harder to
capture his extraordinary gifts and it's
clear that there was something
absolutely extraordinary about Jack
Kennedy the fierce devotion and
affection of his circle was one of the
most striking facts about Kennedy
president's command loyalty of course
especially from their their advisers but
few inspired the intense love that
Kennedy did when he died many members of
his circle commented that they were more
upset by his death than they had been by
the death of their own fathers a good
example the zealous devotion he is fired
was after the assassination Jackie
called Teddy white to come to Hyannis
Port to talk about how Jack Kennedy
should be remembered that day not only
was there a near hurricane over New
England but White's mother was literally
having a heart attack white asked
himself if the widow of my friend needed
me and my mother needed me what should I
do and white made his decision and he
called periodically from the road to ham
sport to check on his mother and this
was incidentally the meeting where
Jackie introduced the idea of the
Kennedy era as Camelot many of Kennedy's
admirers
were prominent people in their own right
often of enormous ego themselves men as
diverse as John Glenn
and Norman Mailer Oleg Cassini and
Robert Frost
David Ormsby Gore and Bobby Baker with
the public
Kennedy inspired surprisingly raw forms
of worship people struggle to get near
him and often tried to kiss his hand his
barber was Dale oozed with requests for
locks of his hair in imitation of his
habits cigar sales soared and hat sales
fell this is true all over the world
Irish cottages displayed pictures of the
Sacred Heart their Blessed Virgin and
President Kennedy in remote villages in
India his picture was hung beside Gandhi
and Nehru when Kennedy visited cities in
West Germany in 1963 the State
Department's William Tyler observed that
Kennedy's popularity went far beyond
anything that could be accounted for by
any act and Kennedy didn't just inspire
admiration he actually stirred people to
action even before he was president
after he gave a university commencement
address when an applicant to the law
school was asked why do you want to
study law he answered I heard senator
Kennedy make his address at the
commencement and I want to prepare
myself seriously to be of service to our
government although Hubert Humphrey and
others had also proposed a Peace Corps
like program the idea didn't ignite
until Kennedy mentioned it during the
campaign and although he made just a
very general proposal it was immediately
met with extraordinary enthusiasm black
Air Force veteran james Meredith was so
moved by hearing Kennedy's inaugural
address that the same night he wrote to
Ole Miss for admission the first step in
a long struggle that would stand as a
great civil rights landmark civil rights
leader James farmer reflected of Kennedy
I adored how he encouraged our movement
by his rhetoric that's not what your
country can do for you ask what you can
do for your country
ah what I can do for my country is to
wipe out segregation we answered when
Lewis Martin Kennedy's one black advisor
told him Negroes are getting ideas they
haven't had before Kennedy asked where
are they getting them Martin answer from
you
you're lifting the horizons of be gross
across the country so many people took
up Kennedy's challenge to March 50 miles
that Kennedy doctors groups issued
health warnings Kennedy found his own
powers unsettling when he gave his
famous benign berliner speech in 1963 to
an adoring mass in West Berlin he the
crowds response was so fervent that he
was first exhilarated but then alarmed
the German Chancellor was also troubled
by the frenzy inspired by Kennedy does
this mean Germany can one day have
another Hitler he asked Kennedy's
extraordinary influence showed in the
world's response to his death a Moscow
reporter observed it was absolutely
fantastic
the impact this assassination has made
in the Soviet Union in France Charles de
Gaulle said I am stunned they're crying
all over France it is as though he were
a Frenchman a member of their own family
the American ambassador in Britain
reported Great Britain has never before
a warren of orner as it is as it has
President Kennedy many demonstrations of
affectionate respect spring from the
hearts of those who believe he might
have become the creator of a new world
order embassies in Africa South America
Asia and elsewhere sport reported an
astonishing response to the news so just
what was it about Kennedy he was the
all-american hero splendid graceful
confident he had a winning personal
style a rapport with reporters and a
glamorous life he died a terrible death
but do we judge him to be truly great
that was the question I struggled with
as I was working on the book and I came
to feel that Kennedy was truly great but
I couldn't articulate for my
satisfaction why I thought so then
something Kennedy himself said made it
clear for me it seems like an
unimportant sentence in what I consider
to be the best speech he ever gave the
short hastily prepared June 1963
TV address about civil rights that
Kennedy made the night he forced George
Wallace to yield to the court-ordered
desegregation of the University of
Alabama in part he said today we are
committed to the worldwide struggle to
promote and protect the rights of all
who wish to be free and when Americans
are sent to Vietnam or West Berlin we do
not ask for whites only it ought to be
possible therefore for American students
of any color to attend any public
institution they select without having
to be backed up by troops it is better
to settle these matters in the courts
than on the streets and new laws are
needed at every level but law alone
cannot make men see right we face
therefore a moral crisis as a country
and as a people
it cannot be met with repressive police
action it cannot be left to increase
demonstrations in the streets it is time
to act in the Congress in your state and
legislative body and above all in all of
our daily lives a great change is at
hand and our task our obligation is to
make that revolution that change
peaceful and constructive for all and
there's one sentence in that speech that
made me realize what was truly
extraordinary about Kennedy law alone
cannot make men see right Kennedy
created the idea of John F Kennedy
a man magnificent enough to capture the
imagination of a people who wouldn't
have attended to a more realistically
portrayed leader board with abstract
concepts the public needs a personality
to dramatize them and although this
seems primitive its necessary the
idealized portrait of John Kennedy is
what people saw and believed it's the
reason that Camelot seems a fitting
description it fulfilled a desire that
still exists and although good looks an
interesting life and a witty style don't
seem substantial enough to account for
the enormous regard for Kennedy
nevertheless it's such superficial
qualities that interest the public in
more serious matters the gift of image
making
though often derided as mere public
relations is what permits great leaders
to inspire trust rally support and sway
public sentiment when Kennedy said ask
not what your country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country the
whole world rose up to answer
Kennedy's glamour heroism and eloquence
were the tools he used to rouse the
country but none of these elements or
even their combination was enough to
create a Kennedy
it was he who transformed them he worked
hard to create an image of John Kennedy
but images take their power from ideas
and the idea that stood behind Kennedy
was excellence perhaps perhaps others
helped write the words that he spoke and
the books that he published but they
wrote those words for him and only he
made them possible and persuasive
Kennedy inspired people with a sense of
hope and possibility with a sense of the
positive achievements of government and
with a standard of excellence in
people's mind he held out a strenuous
vision of dedication to the public good
of commitment to American ideals and of
appreciation for culture and intellect
Kennedy repeatedly urged that the United
States should aim to the highest and in
the first televised election debate with
Nixon he emphasized this is a great
country but I think it could be a
greater country and this is a powerful
country but I think it can be a more
powerful country as said by Kennedy such
statements don't sound like pessimism
but instead a stirring halt to action
Kennedy fixed the public's imagination
on high matters and challenged them to
write action that's why he's on the
cover of a magazine in 2005 and that's
what made Kennedy Kennedy and that's why
he was truly great so I'd be happy to
take questions
and
yes academic at the college level I love
both of your books about Churchill and
Kennedy and I use them in the classroom
and I noticed in the JFK book something
I've not known before that JFK one time
met Winston Churchill on the yacht of
Aristotle Onassis and I guess my
question to you is since you've spent so
much time with these two men Churchill
and Kennedy if you had one hour and you
could spend it with either one of them I
feel like that's a mischievous question
no that that they met on Aristotle
Onassis is God is truly one of these you
can't make it up moments of history I
love John Kennedy but I think no one in
my I think no one could take Churchill's
place for me and yeah he just is such a
piece of work to I think I would have to
say Churchill but but I know I wouldn't
get a word in edgewise if I was if I was
with Churchill I would just be listening
to him whereas Kennedy would be charming
me but they're both they're both so
fascinating I mean imagine what that
meeting must have been like and I know I
know that Jack Kennedy that was very
disappointed in it Churchill didn't pay
very much attention to him and of course
he hated Joe Kennedy who had tried as
hard as he could to keep the United
States out of the war and Jackie needled
Jack leaders saying well you were
wearing you know wipes a white dinner
jacket maybe he thought you were the
waiter so
so I both of them would have been
fascinating companions but anyone else
yes
driver that same energy that President
Kennedy projected his campaigns in his
presidency
do you think that can't be regenerated
four that can be revived for our for our
generation I'm 32 years old
and President Kennedy died 10 years
before I was born so my generation I got
never got to know him except by video or
we saw movies and stuff like that did
you think that same expectation that
same energy to be transferred from one
generation to another you hope that the
same energy could be generated in that
that sort of hope and belief however
given the change nature of the press
it's hard to imagine that a leader could
have that kind of heroic quality because
that heroic quality depends on a sort of
grandeur and distance that we have lost
there's a saying that no man is a hero
to his valet and the reason for that is
that the valet knows too much they see
the private side and all the sordid
details and and sort of embarrassing
moments and because that we know so much
about our leaders that think we're all
in the position of being the valet now
and so we don't look up to them in the
same way and you think of all the things
that Kennedy was able to keep private
even if you leave out sort of the sordid
details but just the much greater
control he had of his image it was a
very great help to him so I'm not sure
you could get someone at this statute or
whether you could get someone who could
generate as much enthusiasm you hope
that they would be able to but they
would have to do it without that tool
that he had that he made such good use
of my top three right now are Leonardo
da Vinci Queen Victoria and Jesus
so I have to I have to consult with my
editor but um but I I love hearing
suggested some prequels so I hope my
website is just Gretchen Rubin comm so
if you have any suggestions for people
many people of course suggest Franklin
Delano Roosevelt because he would so
lend himself TV but you almost have the
eighty ways to look at FDR
but those are my talk places now it's
such a flexible format I really feel
that there's there's a lot of people
that would be really interesting to do
some people have also suggested doing
things like the Civil War doing an event
instead of a person who I that would be
that would be interesting as well yes
various campaign candidate came to
Kansas City and spoke at the municipal
auditorium and there were a lot of
people involved in that event did you
have any Kansas Citians involved in your
review of what you bro you should always
work Kansas City into everything that's
that's a good policy but and you know
with Winston Churchill it was right down
the street from my parents was married
love right there every day I could walk
by it but I didn't I didn't that's
interesting that he that he came here
one thing that's interesting about
Kennedy is everybody remembers where
they were when they heard he was
assassinated but just as I've talked to
people people remember every sort of
every encounter that they had with him
and maybe that's true of every president
but I'm not sure that it's it's I've
been surprised by how people seem to
have such crystal memories of every
connection that they had from him even
you know dating back well before he was
running for president yes actually given
in any sense that what you've defined is
his greatness which is really about his
idealism and his style his words that in
what happened after he died with the
complications of civil rights and the
riots the complications in the Vietnam
that we all know about that his legacy
might have been different if he'd lived
that it was
more complicated world than the world
he'd had to deal with in those first two
years I think that's exactly right and I
think one of the ways we Jack Kennedy
was such a lucky man in so many ways in
many ways he had very bad luck but one
of the most fortunate things that happen
in terms of his legacy was the timing of
his death because he certainly was at a
high moment publicly but there were many
many things that were brewing that would
have been a terrible problem for him
there were investigations going on that
were very likely to lead to revelations
related to a lot of the more sordid side
of what he was doing and Vietnam was
becoming increasingly escalated and it
was hard to see where that was going to
go even some argue that he would have
tried to pull out of Vietnam but how he
would have done that would have been
very difficult if he even sought to do
that civil rights the momentum was
growing and the level of intensity was
growing and certainly by dying when he
did Kennedy is associated with the
ideals but without their negative
consequences so you think of standing
firm for American ideals but you don't
think of the horrors of Vietnam you
think of you know the grandeur of civil
rights but you don't think about forced
busing and riots and so I think you his
legacy was very much and also the fact
that the fact that he didn't accomplish
very much at all is excused by the fact
that he wasn't an office for very long
but he didn't have a good grip on the
Congress he wasn't getting things done
the timing of his death explained all
that yes
towards women's well you can't admire
that on Monday okay
and I have to say I was far worse than I
had known before I got into the research
the it's hard to imagine anybody
behaving like that in the White House
we're just the even if the press isn't
reporting it just the number of people
that are watching you and seeing what
you're up to
so it was hard for me too and that's one
of the advantages I think of the
structure is that instead of having to
come up with one unified vision of
Kennedy that that explains everything
and forces you to come to grips with it
in one way
for example Nigel Hamilton wrote a book
reckless youth and he uses this theme of
recklessness to try to explain
everything about Kennedy it's character
I just sort of can say well on the one
hand he was this tremendous tremendous
ideals and that was a tremendous force
for the good and then in another chapter
you just marched through all the
negatives and people are complicated and
sometimes they have these two sides of
their personality you can't imagine how
they can exist in the same person but
they do yeah there was a popular
comedian in the 60s a personated John
Kennedy and
in other people's impersonated Bobby and
Jackie
kind of part of the pop culture and hold
it I think it pulled it country under
there into the White House did you kind
of cross that at all Vince meter I'm
having the bond meter yes yes no that
was that was very funny but you know was
considered very threatening at the time
I mean now you see how you know Saturday
Night Live makes fun of the President
and there's all this stuff but at the
time it was it was very questionable and
Jackie Kennedy tried to get I think the
Secret Service to shut it down but if
I'm remembering correctly but yeah it
was that kind of thing but but Jack
Kennedy joked about it and said oh I
really think he sounds more like Teddy
and it was a good example of how he he
was so comfortable with himself and his
image and he was able to convey that
with two people so something that might
have been seen as making him look a
little ridiculous he just laughed it off
in a way that made him seem all the more
secure and admirable yes did you feel
like
it certainly was I mean you never
understand somebody else's marriage and
this is a good example of it because you
know I have a chapter where I said that
they had a good marriage and and they
didn't have a good marriage I sort of
present both sides and in some ways they
were this amazing team of people who
work together it was such an
extraordinary success and it seemed like
Jack Kennedy had growing affection and
respect for his wife but then on the
other hand there were all these things
he did that were you know very
neglectful I think he was only in the
same city when his wife had a baby for
one child and they had four children
that were born you know two didn't
survive but you know one out of four is
not a good track record for a father and
and he even said I never there when she
needs me so I had a growing sense of
just the inexplicable 'ti of how other
people live their lives especially you
know when there's it's so public so many
people were watching them one thing that
was very interesting to me was how smart
Jackie Kennedy was I hadn't realized
that when you read them to her memos and
what she did I mean it's extraordinary
to think that she was 31 years old and
she came in and just did everything a
different way in the White House and it
didn't listen to anybody's advice as
much as they tried to boss her around if
she really must have had an
extraordinary personality and just
really came into her own as the first
lady
all day with the Bay of Pigs and mafia
what do you think about these things
disturbing theories coming up do you
think there's anything to them I really
think that the evidence is absolutely
overwhelming and it becomes more
overwhelming with all the more
sophisticated techniques that they use
that as simple as it is Lee Harvey
Oswald acting alone killed the president
and the man who shot the president was
arrested 90 minutes after it happened
and that was it what I think is more
interesting is why Americans are so
fascinated by the conspiracies and why
they hold on to them in the face of
overwhelming evidence that there's a
very simple answer to this to this
question and I think part of it what and
I thought a lot about it in the book and
I in writing the book and I think part
of it is the idea that you can't have
such a dramatic and terrible result with
such a simple cause it's not enough that
a 24 year old guy sent away in the mail
for a rifle and got it and then went up
into his office building and just looked
out the window and shot the president it
seems like something what's more than
that had to have been involved even
though that's really all it took and I
think another thing is is that Kennedy
is this huge flame of fame and attention
and people want to be part of that and
if you have a new theory and you have a
new angle a new photograph that you're
looking at in a different way or you
know a new witness who although they're
on the record saying one thing on the
day of the assassination now they're
saying they saw something else that's a
hook that you can use to write a book
and write get your self on a video or
interviewed on a cable channel and
people want to cling on to that and so
they perpetuate these conspiracy
theories that's a way to participate and
I think also people do it in tribute to
Kennedy it's a way that they can become
part of the Kennedy legacy if they can
solve this mystery then that will be
their way of giving allegiance to him so
I think all these things keep the
conspiracy theory against theories going
even though they're just not there's
nothing there
so I think we have time for one more yes
it's procedures there amongst the 19
cities raid that America will ever know
the real truth
the way it was planned out and
everything fell again and that the
sub-ether word and suddenly it didn't
say from then to now well we do think
you ever think that the real truth for
we young and we really won't know what
happened I think we do know I think we
know that Lee Harvey Oswald did it Lee
Harvey Oswald how he had the personality
he had the background he was a
sharpshooter he had a rifle he had tried
to assassinate someone just months
before he had an office that was on it
clearly publicized
the clearly publicized motorcade route
Kennedy was well within range he had
time to shoot his fingerprints were
there his gun was used you know he was
running away part of the mystery of
course is that he was shot by Jack Ruby
and that sealed Lee Harvey Oswald in
Fame if he were languishing in a prison
changing his story every every couple of
weeks and panting after attention I
think the public would have lost
interest in him long ago
as it is now his his signature is worth
more than Kennedy's